foreign
what happens when a Syrian refugee and
Israeli Aid worker and an American Jew
walk into a room
no this is not the start of a really bad
joke I promise this actually happened to
me
starting in 2015
I found myself holding a series of
secret meetings in various European
capitals with a small group of Syrian
and Israeli civilians
and we were there to try and figure out
how we can get Aid to the Syrian people
who were enduring the worst humanitarian
crisis since World War II
but how did we end up at this table
together after all syrians and Israelis
are sworn enemies and technically
they've been in a state of War since
1948.
yet here we were literally and
figuratively trying to find a way in
and here's the punch line of that bad
joke I promised not to tell
we found it
we figured out a way to get Aid into
Syria
through Israel
now
how did we do that
I applied a three-step process that I've
used in a bunch of other settings and
I'm hoping that those three steps will
be useful to any of you
who want to do some good in the face of
any of the Myriad overwhelming conflicts
that we're facing today including
Ukraine
so what are my three steps
find an entry point
identify a gap
and then find something doable with
which to fill that Gap it sounds pretty
simple right so let me walk you through
it
when I read a report on the Syrian War
it hit me very hard and it felt very
personal
I was stunned by the scale of the misery
and it echoed the suffering of my own
family during the Holocaust
my parents survived concentration camps
in Poland and in Hungary
and after the war we had to flee and we
arrived in the U.S as stateless refugees
so when I saw the destruction of Aleppo
I was put in mind of Budapest the city
of my birth the bombed out city of my
birth
and when I read about starvation by
Siege in Syria
I remembered my own mother who lost a
pregnancy lugging a sack of rotten
potatoes home because there was nothing
else to eat
and when I saw the eviscerated and
emaciated corpses of syrians who had
been tortured and Damascus prisons
I also saw the walking skeletons of
Auschwitz mouthhausen and bergen-belson
where so many of my own family members
literally went up in smoke
and when I saw Syrian refugees flooding
across borders
I also recalled my own displacement as a
refugee child
so as one person
as one person what can you do next
when you're confronted with something
that you know needs to be changed
you have to find an entry point
for me that was mobilizing a Jewish
response and then scaling that up to the
inter-religious response in the U.S
focused exclusively on Syria
it's called The multi-faith Alliance for
Syrian refugees and today we have more
than 100 partner organizations
thank you
I saw an opportunity to build Bridges
while also saving lives and and here's
how
the Southwest part of Syria was very
difficult to access because it was
surrounded by regime forces
that was a gap
Israel shares a border with that part of
Syria and guess what it's easy to get
Aiden to Southwest Syria from the
Israeli side of the Golan Heights that
gave us something doable with which to
fill that Gap all we needed was the how
and that's why my colleagues and I found
ourselves in clandestine meetings all
over Europe we were making the case that
Israel should be used as a staging area
for the outbound delivery of
international
humanitarian Aid
we lobbied the UK Parliament the EU
Parliament the Canadian Parliament we
banged on doors in Congress we met with
every level of government in Israel and
we got nowhere
but then it happened
in September 2016
the Israeli government launched
operation Good Neighbor it was Now
official government policy to open the
border so that aid from other countries
could be facilitated
and sent into Syria
so soon after
once we were able to get operation Good
Neighbor going
soon after enormous cargo containers of
Aid many of them bearing goods from
Syrian organizations were being unloaded
in Israeli ports by Israeli soldiers
sent over to Golan Heights and from
there our partners on the ground in
Syria would pick up the aid and
distribute it to an area with a
population of 1.3 million people
we delivered 120 million dollars of Aid
this way we supported three medical
facilities a bakery that produced 15 000
pitas a day
the Israelis provided water fuel
electricity we shipped medical equipment
ambulances food clothing sanitary kits
medicine whatever else was needed
and by working through local councils we
were able to help stabilize an entire
region for two years this was the only
part of Syria that worked
but then because of an incursion by the
regime and its allies that area was
completely taken over and destroyed
but that did not stop us
we expanded our deliveries to other hard
to reach parts of Syria
today we have delivered nearly 245
million dollars in Aid
it wasn't easy
and it wasn't without hiccups
but by working with these unlikely
Partnerships
we were able to help more than two and a
half million War victims and still
counting
now here's the great news
you don't have to go to a war zone to do
this
I've applied my formula in a bunch of
other settings so let me share a couple
of quick stories with you
um early in my career 1971 to be exact
I was living a life of crime crime
prevention that is
I was also deeply immersed in the
women's movement so where could I make a
difference
my entry point was the New York City
Police Department
victims of sexual assault were being
very badly treated that was a gap
the doable way to fill that Gap was to
set up the first sex crimes unit in the
country well today we've got Law and
Order SVU to tell us how it's done in
fact they've been telling us how it's
done for the past 23 Seasons but back
then back then this was a new idea
I've done the same thing with large
corporations
when the New Millennium was approaching
the human resources field was laser
focused on workplace 2000 with diversity
being a key goal
but religion was very rarely looked at
as an aspect of workplace diversity yet
if you looked at the change of changing
demographics it was obvious that this
was going to be a big issue so that was
a gap
another organization I founded the
Tannenbaum Center for inter-religious
understanding found a doable way to fill
that Gap by guiding major corporations
in accommodating religious beliefs in
the workplace
well
it's um it's been a long road to Syria
from my early forays as a professional
change agent
but when I saw the Syrian tragedy unfold
a Biblical verse Leviticus 19 16 kept
reverberating in my brain
Thou shalt not stand idly by while the
blood of your neighbor cries out from
the Earth
well that's why I got to work
I hope you will too
thank you